so far we've talked all things global
load balancing on Google cloud platform
but how does this work with google
kubernetes clusters running as backends
well stay tuned to find out
[Music]
[Applause]
since last time beyond treats online
business has still been booming and
while they upgraded to using Google's
global load balancer they also decided
to move to a micro services environment
for their read back end but load
balancers were initially built to
support resource allocation for virtual
machines which helps workloads be highly
available when containers and container
orchestrators started to take off users
adapted these VM focused load balancers
for their use even though the
performance was suboptimal traditionally
HTTP load balancers targeting kubernetes
casters would actually be targeting its
nodes because they didn't have a way to
recognize each pod in the absence of a
way to define a group of pods as
backends the load balancer used instance
groups to group Williams as a back-end
ingress support in gke using those
instance groups used the HTTP load
balancer to perform load balancing to
nodes in the cluster IP table rules
programmed on the nodes route requests
to the pods serving as backends for the
load balanced application load balancing
to the nodes was the only option since
the load balancer didn't recognize pods
or containers as backends resulting in
imbalance load and a suboptimal data
path with additional unnecessary hops
between nodes but then Google came out
with Network endpoint groups or next
abstraction layer that enables container
native load balancing this means the
load balancer has visibility into a
kubernetes cluster spots because Meg's
are integrated with the kubernetes
ingress controller running on GCP in the
case for beyond treat they have a
multi-tiered ecommerce deployment and
want to expose one service to the
internet using gke with negs they can
now provision an HTTP load balancer
allowing them to configure path based or
host based routing to their back-end
pods all I have to do to get started is
to create a VPC native gke cluster by
default kubernetes uses static routes
for pod networking which requires the
kubernetes control plane to maintain
these routes to each node but this comes
out of scaling cost and gke you have the
option to create clusters in VPC native
mode which provides container native
load balancing that uses an
model BBC native mode means you have
connectivity between all pods in your V
PC without the overhead of route scaling
and traffic is evenly distributed among
the available healthy backends and an
employed group now that beyond treat has
implemented a V PC native cluster with
legs they've experienced even better
load balancing with container native
load balancing traffic is distributed
evenly among the available healthy
backends in an end point group following
their defined load balancing algorithm
they also now have native support for
health checking including TCP HTTPS or
HTTP 2 checks Meg's can check the pods
directly rather than the nodes
forwarding health checks to a random pod
as a result health checks more
accurately mirror the health of the
backends beyond treat also benefits from
graceful termination meaning when a part
is removed the load balancer
automatically drains the connection to
the endpoint serving traffic based on
the connection draining period
configured for it and best yet there pet
lovers will experience their traffic
hitting an optimal data path with the
ability to load balance directly to
containers the traffic hop from the load
balancer to the node disappears since
load balancing is performed in a single
step rather than to and beyond treat now
has increased visibility and security
container native load balancing helps
them troubleshoot their services at the
pod level it can preserve the source IP
to make it easier to trace back to the
source of the traffic since the
container sees the packet arrived from
the load balancer rather than through a
source NAT from another node they can
now create firewall rules using node
level network policies
it looks like beyond tree has gone from
the popular local bakery to an
international online bakery phenomenon
and it's GCP backend has grown along
with it we learned about the load
balancing options on GCP and proved
their global load balancing is more
performant and reliable than regional
HTTP load balancing and finally we
showed you that even with gke clusters
container native load balancing means
they can target back in pods directly
for optimal traffic distribution and
improvements in scalability alright
we've been talking about trees for weeks
and
we can refer to transom that's all for
today on get cooking in cloud let us
know how you're lighting the series in
the comments section and hit those like
and subscribe buttons for more cool
Google cloud content
[Music]